>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Melissa Block: Good evening
everybody, thank you so much
for coming and spending a bit
of your evening with us tonight,
I'm delighted to be here on stage
with these two incredible historians
and biographers and all
around great people.
I'm Melissa Block, with
National Public Radio and PR,
Annette Gordon-Reed and Peter
Onuf, as you know the authors
of the new book Most
Blessed of the Patriarchs.
And we're going to talk about
Thomas Jefferson and other things,
so welcome to all of you and
again thanks for being with us
on this beautiful night I
should say, you're indoors
on a gorgeous Washington night.
I want to start with the title
of the book, The Most Blessed
of the Patriarchs, which you
talk about in the preface
of the book coming from a letter
that Thomas Jefferson
writes in 1793.
So he's back from Paris, he's back
home, he's not quite back home
but he's planning on going
back to Monticello in Virginia.
He's writing a letter to
Angelica Schuyler Church which,
for those of us who have been
steeped in the Hamilton sound track,
can I hear the name without
thinking Angelica, Eliza.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: And Peggy.
>> Melissa Block: And Peggy -- he's
writing to Angelica Schuyler Church
in London talking about his
plans to go back to Monticello,
and part of the letter reads as
follows: I have my house to build,
my fields to form and to
watch for the happiness
of those who labor for mine.
I have one daughter married
to a man of science, sense,
virtue and competence in whom
indeed I have nothing more to wish.
They live with me, if the other
shall be as fortunate in due process
of time I shall imagine
myself as blessed
as the most blessed
of the patriarchs.
So Annette Gordon-Reed why don't you
talk a little bit about what it was
in that seemingly innocuous
paragraph in a letter to Angelica --
you're taking umbrage at innocuous.
But what was it about that
language that intrigued you
and made you think that
was root of this book?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
Well, first I want to say
that the title was somewhat
controversial, we had to fight
to have quotes because this is
a Jefferson quote about himself
and we didn't want people to think
that we were calling him the
most blessed of the blessed
of the patriarchs because
I thought you know --
>> Peter S. Onuf: Because I'm the
most blessed of the patriarchs.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Peter
might be able to get away with that
but of course I could not get away
with calling Jefferson
the most blessed
of the blessed of patriarchs.
But we thought it was intriguing
because it is so different
from the idea of being a -- you the
apostle of liberty, a Republican,
a person who saw himself
as an avatar
of the enlightenment calling
himself something that calls
to mind an ancient patriarch.
It's biblical, it's ancient times
and he in another letter refers
to himself as living at Monticello
like an Antediluvian patriarch.
So he's the harbinger of the new
but at the same time he is seeing
himself as this figure, a patriarch.
So we thought we would try
to unpack that as they say --
historians say because we've
sort of come to a point
where there's a set picture
of Jefferson and a lot
of what people are doing and
writing about him is writing
about what they wish he had done or
that they're mad that he didn't do.
And we wanted to try to figure out
what did he think he was doing,
which is sort of an important
thing we think to try to uncover.
>> Melissa Block: You're
trying really
to get inside his head
as much as you can.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And we want
to draw attention to what seems
to be a paradox because the past as
is well-known is a foreign country
and our idea is that Jefferson
studies have been distorted
by the need to make
him speak to us now.
And we're not going to be able
to draw anything from Jefferson
until we can put him in his
place and that was our goal.
>> Melissa Block: How do you think
he interpreted that patriarchy
that he's talking about, what
is he talking about there,
what does that symbolize for him?
>> Peter S. Onuf: He wasn't
embarrassed to use the term
and I think that's something
that we need to explore
and that was the point of
this, how could he say this
and what does it signify and
the point of departure for us is
that the world he created
for himself
at Monticello is foundational to
his career in American History.
His public life is not
disconnected from his private life.
If you want to understand
Jefferson you have
to put those two things together.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: And seeing
himself as a patriarch is sort
of accepting his position in the
world, this is a person who's born
at the top of the hierarchy in
Virginia, he's you know, he's white,
he's male, he's the first son.
He's tall, he's intelligent, he's
well-educated and he sees himself
as having a special role.
It's sort of an interesting thing
to think of somebody who is sort
of in the middle of nowhere
who decides that he is going
to be a mover and shaker in
the world, that he is going
to sort of make his mark.
And he's actually able to do that
through the force of a personality
that is very self-assured,
confident,
you might say arrogant in a way.
But certainly believing that he
had a special place and patriarch
to us is -- it's a negative
thing for most people maybe,
it's a problematic concept but it
was not problematic to him at all
because he's thinking I'm
doing this the right way.
And that's the thing that's
great I think a lot --
>> Peter S. Onuf: And it's
important to keep in mind
that Jefferson's whole career is
dedicated to eradicating aristocracy
and that's a challenge for us
because aristocracy and monarchy,
patriarchy, these are
all dirty words for us.
That's the old regime, Jefferson saw
himself inaugurating a new regime,
he didn't reject, however, this
fundamental notion of the centrality
of the family and the household
to the future of the republic.
And that's what he's celebrating
is the role he's playing
in his household.
>> Melissa Block: So
does that notion
of patriarchy do you think
extend beyond the household,
beyond Monticello, his
family, his enslaved workers
to how he approached the
presidency, to politics [inaudible]?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: He didn't
think of himself as a patriarch.
>> Peter S. Onuf: That
was Washington.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Washington--
no he may have thought he was
really the father of the country,
Jefferson may have thought he was
the real father of the country
but I don't think he -- he did
not see himself as a patriarch
of the people of -- Americans,
I mean the people were supposed
to be the rulers but I think
his understanding of family
and how people should relate
to one another was central,
it came from his conception
of what family was like at --
what he conceived family was
supposed to be like at Monticello.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Well,
do you remember
when the nuclear family
was [inaudible]
that is most Americans
lived in nuclear families,
some of you probably still
do, a few of you at least.
But Jefferson thought it was natural
and that's a key word
for him is nature.
If a family comes together naturally
and he imagines the republic is the
most natural form of government,
it's self-government, it's true
to the nature of human beings.
Therefore, the United States will
be a kind of model to the world.
>> Melissa Block: Let's
talk about the structure
of the book a little bit
because you approach it
in a really interesting way, you're
not -- you're moving chronologically
but you're not focused on his
political life where the minutia
of his time as president you have
chapters on music and on privacy
and how vital privacy was to him.
Why don't you talk a little bit
about how you came to that approach
and why you approached it that way.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: We
wanted to do something different,
we wanted try to show
what we thought,
the things that we
thought were important
to shaping Jefferson's
life and we've done --
you know he was born in Shadwell
and then one thing happened
and then the other thing
happened, another thing happened.
The idea was to have things,
things that were important to him,
things that we think are sort
of key to his personality.
We start out with patriarchy and
sort of unpack that and think
about how he became a patriarch,
the second section is traveler
and it talks about the influence
of France, what happened to him
when he leaves Monticello
and Shadwell
and goes out into the world.
And the last one is called
enthusiast, and that's where we talk
about music and visitors and things
that are not, the sort of influences
that shaped him but would
not be in a typical kind
of biography thought
in that particular way.
The idea was to sort of get
inside of his head in a fashion
and not just do sort of the
laundry list of details.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And if we
successfully integrate his private
life into his public like then
we can show how the performances
that he orchestrates in his
house then appeal to him
and in a way it's a microcosm of
how he imagines the world should be.
Civil conversation, music in
which everybody knows her part
and they harmonize.
There's a political meaning to all
this, I think it's profoundly basic
to his political philosophy,
the idea about Jefferson is
you can never know who he is
and we think that's
stupid, it's foolish.
He's supposed to be impenetrable,
he's been called a sphinx, well,
Jefferson himself made a
big deal about his privacy,
you mentioned that Melissa and
that privacy is foundational
to how he understands
his public life.
Take this simple idea, in a
republic citizens are equal,
they have to consent to the laws
that the majority decides on
and that consent has to be
truly voluntary, it has to come
from the self determination
of the individual,
so how do you protect individuals
from insidious influences.
How do you take for instance the
common person out of the mob,
how do you avoid the usual
problems or pathologies of democracy
because democracy was a
dirty word in the street?
Put a bunch of people together
and they're going to get drunk
and if they had a government
and they controlled the
government what would you do?
Well, you would pass an agrarian law
that means you'd redistribute
property.
So how do you lift people
up, that's his big challenge
and crucial is the project
of lifting people up,
true republican government is a new
conception of the consenting self.
And Jefferson's project we described
as a self-fashioning project
to make himself somebody, he wants
to exemplify how an enlightened
republican criticize can become well
informed and can become
a part of a new kind
of public life based
on informed consent.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: He sees
himself you might say as an avatar,
he sees himself as an
example of all of this.
There's sort of an arrogance to
this, the idea that he's sort
of the national teacher, that he
is sort of an example to people.
And that's what Monticello
is supposed to be,
I mean you go to Monticello
if you've been there,
you go into the Indian Hall and
the foyer there, there's all kinds
of you know paintings and sculptures
and everything and the idea is
that these are things that
he's brought back with him
from France to show to people.
And he's going to show
people how to be --
to model this civilized behavior
and so it's an interesting idea
to say that I am an example.
You know of something that
I want other people to see
and this is how you
model yourself in the way
to be educational to other people.
>> Melissa Block: Speaking
of the consenting self
and obviously a whole
category of people who were
by no means [cross-talk].
But I'm curious I mean
obviously Annette Gordon-Reed
as you know wrote the seminal
book, The Hemingses of Monticello,
they spent a lot of time looking
into the family, the extended family
of Thomas Jefferson
through Sally Hemings.
Did you come to a different
understanding
of how he viewed slavery, so much
has been written, you studied it
so many times, this fatal
stain as he described it.
You do spend some time talking about
how when he goes to France you say
in France slavery became fully
domesticated in his mind,
what is that, what does that mean?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: What it
means is before he went to France,
Jefferson had a reputation
as being antislavery.
The first indication of this, he's a
young man in his 20's and he copies
into his common place
book parts of a poem.
When William Shenstone that talks
about the evils of the slave trade
and somebody yanked from
his native land to --
you know brought across the
ocean to labor for someone else.
And he as a young legislator
wanted to introduce legislation
to for emancipation plan, which
nowhere in Virginia, went no place
and he wrote about this and
as I said had a reputation
as being antislavery.
Well, when he goes to France and he
sees French society in a situation
where you go, you leave
your country and you think
that there are bad things about
your country, you go someplace else
and you say well at least
we're not like that.
You can be French you know,
that was his attitude he saw --
he's in France during the
prerevolutionary period
and people are starving, there's
unrest, bread riots all kinds
of things and he says, you know
we have problems in America
but this place has lots of problems.
And they're just on the road
no to being able to solve some
of those problems because he
was very, very much in favor
of the French Revolution.
He was excited by all of that.
It gave him a sense
that well we have time
to solve our problems as well.
The other thing that happens he's in
France with James and Sally Hemings
who are his wife's half siblings.
And he begins to treat them there
in a way, he pays them wages
and he's starts a practice that he
continues when he comes back home,
that is paying whenever he's in a
city and he's mixing enslaved labor
and free labor, he pays everybody
because I guess it
causes less of a conflict.
He's living there with these people
who have an opportunity to be free
because every person who
petitioned for freedom
in France, it was granted.
So like a pro forma thing
which they could have done,
James and Sally Hemings could
have done but they didn't do
and while he's there he's
living with these people
who become the face of
slavery for him in a way.
Jefferson, and he continues this
when he comes home, he sees himself
as a [inaudible] through his
relationship with the people
who were the closest to him, who are
around him but that's unrealistic.
Because they're not the people down
the mountain, they're not the bulk
of -- this is his wife's family
and they have a completely
different relationship
to him than the others do.
I mean Sally Hemings' brothers
lots of times he didn't know
where they were, I mean they
hired their own time and went out
and kept the money and you
know he would call them back
when he needed them for something so
that's a very different relationship
that he had with the vast over
700 people, we think that he owned
over the course of his life time.
This is a tiny, tiny group
of people who were pulled
out so he sees himself as a slave
owner through those relationships.
And we think France really
heightened that for him
and because they do come back
with him, they don't stay.
And slavery becomes domesticated,
he's thinking about them as members
of his household, and how he treats
people in his household but that's
as I said is very, very
different than the situation.
>> Peter S. Onuf: There's a kind
of reciprocity then it's not
symmetrical, they're not equal
but like family members and I
use the word natural before,
he has created what he thinks
is a kind of family that extends
and I think that it's using the
right word when she says face,
this is how he sees or
wants to see slavery.
But the other crucial thing to keep
in mind is that Jefferson's urgency
in doing something
about slavery varies
with the GO political situation.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Yes.
>> Peter S. Onuf: To put
it narrowly and neatly
in the American revolution, enslaved
people could run the British lines
and join the counter revolution
later on in the revolution
and what becomes Haiti --
the possibility of
uprising in the hemisphere,
could spread to the continent,
drain the War of 1812.
The British come again and
it's another opportunity
for enslaved people to
take advantage of this.
At moments like this Jefferson
says my fellow Republicans,
we've got to do something
about this.
I know slavery is an unjust
institution we need to act
and his solution of
course is emancipation,
we have to free these people,
this is a radical injustice,
he never backs off from that.
And then we have to send
them to another country,
expatriation is his solution.
>> Melissa Block: To
Liberia and [inaudible].
>> Peter S. Onuf: To
wherever, he thinks about maybe
in the Trans Mississippi, but well
after all we might
need that territory.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: No
not there like California.
>> Peter S. Onuf: He thinks
about Sandemang [phonetic]
because there there's a black
republic it's not recognized as such
but well maybe Africa but
that's very expensive.
He goes through all
these possibilities
but the important thing is that when
the peace comes the urgency goes.
When the peace comes then he
sees himself and I think this is
where this is crucial,
as a master he's a kind
of steward, he has a responsibility.
Just as the father in the
family has a responsibility
and he has a responsibility to
look after the happiness of those
who labor for mine to borrow
another phrase from that letter
that we started off
with in our title.
And then we have a
kind of domestication
and that's talking about, that
is we're trying to create a sense
within this household of good
treatment, he's an emulator,
he wants to improve things, he
wants to rationalize things.
There are ways in other words
in which he can practice
the enlightenment at home,
make things better while we
wait for his fellow Virginians
to see the light, to use that
[inaudible] again and then come
to the collective decision
we have to do something
to end this unjust institution.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Because
he understands, he doesn't believe
that there's what he would call a
Republican solution to the problem,
that is to say white people of
Virginia were not going to vote
to do away with slavery,
that's not going to happen.
I mean during his lifetime that's
not going the only way [inaudible]
but he knew that that was not
going to happen at the time,
it was going to end
by the time he gets
to the Missouri crisis he realizes
that it could end pretty much the
way it ended and that is with a war
and that is not something that
he would have contemplated.
I mean yeah, I think Jefferson
and Haiti is fascinating
because when he first hears
about it and he writes a letter
to his daughter, he's like well
you know the Negros have taken
over the island which is going
to happen in the Caribbean
and that's the -- it was sort
of like oh isn't this the age
of revolution and we've got the
French and all of a sudden he hears
that lots of white people are being
killed and then the tone changes.
It's not -- it's one thing for white
people to kill for their freedom
in France essentially which he
supported the French revolution far
longer than people think he should
have but for the black republic,
you know at first it's okay but then
when they start killing
then it's not okay.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Of course
that reinforces that idea
of racial national difference and I
think one of the key terms we play
with is the very idea of race,
which doesn't have a fixed
meaning at this period.
It's equivalent to nation, people,
race in the modern sense, ethnicity
and if enslaved Africans
and African-Americans are a distinct
people nation race then how could
they possibly live with the
people who had enslaved them.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Yeah,
but there would be no peace
and that's the thing that
really gives people a problem
about Jefferson because we
congratulate ourselves and think
that well we're better,
we're enlightened now,
we're all living together in
peace and harmony, yeah, right?
>> Peter S. Onuf: Oh,
come on, we get along.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: We get --
>> Melissa Block: It's
going well up here.
I'm happy.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
You're happy, you're happy.
We're kind of getting along.
We're getting along yeah but I mean
but he doesn't have the confidence
that -- how could blacks love a
country that has treated them --
>> Peter S. Onuf: No, exactly.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: So
poorly, how could you do
that because this is him
saying I know what I would do
and so transferring, basically
saying that other people --
>> Peter S. Onuf: That's
the down side
of like a sentimental conception of
what nation is a great big family.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
Who love each other.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Yeah, well how
long did it take for the laws
to change on interracial
marriage in America.
I mean we're talking about
basic stuff for Jefferson,
would I want my daughters
to marry black people.
This is insane and so that idea
of the unnaturalness
of the races mixing --
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: But except,
it's interesting we talk about this
in the book that it's very, very,
it's the attitude of the conqueror,
white men have access to the
bodies of white women, black women,
Native American women but
not the other way around.
And so really for Jefferson and
those in the state of Virginia
when he's talking about mixing
he's talking about the horror
of the mixing of white yes
of a black men having
access to white women.
To white women -- to black
women, black men having access
to white women, that's the
problem, he didn't have any problem
with the other way around it because
he knows, he knows that in slavery,
slavery is a laboratory
for that kind of thing.
>> Melissa Block: In
his own household.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: In his own
household, in his own household,
in his father-in-law, people in
Virginia just in general it's clear
that this is something
that was a big part
of life during that time period.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Think
about the implications
of abolishing artificial
hierarchy's among white people,
that is aristocracy, monarchy
all people are white people,
citizens are created
equal but you can do that
but then you draw attention
to divisions
that you consider natural,
not artificial.
To have a king what does a king
do, Thomas Payne tells us all
about this in Common Sense.
He's just descended from a French
bastard, there's nothing legitimate,
a very important word in regimes,
there's nothing legitimate
about monarchy so you abolish
all those things and we agree
on that, we celebrate this.
This was the first
grade modern republic,
yet what that then
draws your attention
to is well how is society
constituted,
what are the natural sorts
of relations that emerge.
And we'd like to think that would
mean everybody who's involved
in the revolution, we'd let the
loyalists go back to Britain,
or the maritime provinces.
They're going to love each
other; it's going to be fine.
But there's a distinction
here, a distinction that runs
down through the society itself,
we have two peoples
living in one place.
It's unnatural because it's vitally
important to have this relationship
to the land, to your country,
this is what patriotism
means is love of country.
And we have a people
here against their will
who we own unjustly,
this is impossible.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
They cannot look --
they cannot love us and we won't
love them and they cannot love us
and we cannot form families,
how can you be equal citizens
if you cannot be in the same family.
Yes, we're all equal the same but
you can't be my daughter-in-law,
you can't be my son-in-law.
>> Melissa Block: You
include part of a letter
that Thomas Jefferson writes
to John Adams towards the end
of both their lives,
there's this historic miracle
that both John Adams and Thomas
Jefferson die on the same day,
on July 4th, fifty
years after the signing
of the Declaration of Independence.
He says time which outlives all
things will outlive this evil also,
clearly taking the long
view [inaudible] who knows
when exactly he's thinking
that will happen.
>> Peter S. Onuf: But remember
he believes in the afterlife.
>> Melissa Block: That's
true he believes
in the afterlife imagine
him looking down.
But I'm curious in his writings
and his letters he talks of slavery
on a grand scale as an institution
but does he ever refer to it
within the context of his family.
Does he talk about any of the
paradox or the contradiction
that we see now in his relations
with Sally Hemings or any
of the other enslaved people on
the plantation, in a direct way.
Does he wrestle with that ever?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: No,
he's not wrestling with this,
he's not wrestling with Sally
Hemings, you know talking
about Sally Hemings
or anything like that.
He doesn't as I was saying before he
sees himself as being a good master
to these people and is not
-- to my family and it's not,
this is not something that is
keeping him up at night and most
of the time that he's talking
about slavery it's at the request
of somebody, somebody has written
to him and asked him about it.
He's not being proactive,
going out [inaudible].
>> Peter S. Onuf: If he were
from New England he'd feel guilty
and he wouldn't sleep
at night, but he's not.
>> Melissa Block: He's a Virginian.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Yeah.
>> Melissa Block: No offense.
You, I'm sorry.
>> Peter S. Onuf: No I was going
to say though there's a lot
of projection in Jefferson,
when I least liked Jefferson,
when I most dislike him is
when solution to any problem,
why there is a problem it's
somebody else's fault and this idea
of the scenario that we sketched out
of how you would have emancipation
in Virginia the white majority
finally realized it has to act
because that's the basic
republican requirement.
Well, whose fault is it and
he says this repeatedly,
I have made it clear
what my position is,
this is the only solution
you're going to have to wake
up to this and now as you quoted.
It's going to take an age;
it's not going to happen
in my life time but
it's not his fault.
See that's where we have the
problem, we said Jefferson come on,
go to church, get down,
apologize, I mean feel bad.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Get down?
Get down on your knees.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Is that idiomatic?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: I
have no idea what that means.
>> Melissa Block: Pray
for forgiveness.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Gosh.
>> Melissa Block: I
have to say one of my --
shifting gears here just a
little bit before this gets
too controversial.
You talk about exploding some of
the myths around Thomas Jefferson
and one of my favorites I have
to say is the notion that he goes
to France as a minister to France
he arrives in 1784 in [inaudible]
and as you describe it,
promptly flees by porters
because he really spoke
very little French.
He studied French, he was
[inaudible] he knew all sorts
of things but his language
skills were not up to snuff.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Well,
he knew how to read French
and if you -- I mean speaking a
language is very, very different,
I mean difficult, I mean it's
one thing to study something
and then actually go to France and
having people speak in the normal,
it sounds like a mile a minute
but the normal way of speaking
to sort of pull it altogether.
He read French well and
he can understand people
but he had difficulty
speaking the language.
His daughters and Sally Hemings and
James Hemings eventually learned how
to speak pretty well but he was
older when he goes to France.
He was in his 40's and
language is not easily acquired
at that time period.
My favorite story about of
that time period is him going
to a chess club and --
>> Melissa Block: In Paris.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: In Paris and
then getting beaten really easily,
handily by people and
he doesn't go back.
And we think that's
interesting because my husband
who played chess competitively
said the only way
to get better playing chess
is to play with people
who are better than you are.
And it's sort of an interesting
thing that he did not --
he loved to play chess but
he did not want to do it,
he didn't love it enough,
to go get beat repeatedly
until he got better
and better at it.
So some very thin skinned
person [inaudible].
>> Peter S. Onuf: And he's
very anxious and it's --
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
You identify with that.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Yeah, I'm a
white guy it's hard but when he's
in France what is most remarkable
to us I think beyond the initial
culture shock and his need
to create a little Virginia at
home, so he could be comfortable.
He needs a comfort zone, it's
the danger he feels that lurks
in French society to
impressionable young people,
he can barely resist
the temptations himself
so young people don't
go to Paris because --
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
You got women who are
in the streets you know
messing in politics.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And that's why he
celebrates the properly constituted
republican family where women have
their place, they play their role
but they're not doing politics,
they're not influencing society,
they're in their place
and he's upset with this.
And it has a lot to do with
sexuality with the temptations
that he sees there and one of his
letters he suggests that if you come
to France at an impressionable
age two things will happen to you.
You'll develop a taste for
whores and you'll never learn
to speak your own language well
because during this crucial period
you'll be speaking another language
and having too much of a good time.
And what's really important
you know --
what's really important is that
you're going to have to go back
in a republic, the key art
in a republic is persuasion,
you know speaking well,
oratory is very important.
So if you can't speak
the language well
and if you're proclivities
sexually develop
in this abnormal pathological
way, then the very foundation
of the republic is
going to be subverted.
>> Melissa Block: I'm want to leave
time for questions but I do want
to ask you one thing, as
co-authors of this book
and I'm enjoying listening to
your slight disagreements here.
Were there points when
you really couldn't agree,
I mean how did you divide --
>> Peter S. Onuf: Tell the story --
>> Melissa Block: Did you
go chapter by chapter,
did have to come to consensus.
>> Peter S. Onuf: She's going to
talk about religion now, okay.
I pray you do.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Oh,
I suppose the biggest dispute
between us was Jefferson's
Christianity.
Peter, he calls himself
a lapsed Unitarian.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Redundant.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: And my
thing was always how could you tell
and I grew up in the
United Methodist tradition
and Jefferson calling himself
a Christian I was not convinced
about that.
And I was sort of --
>> Peter S. Onuf: That's when I was
reduced to prayer at that point.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
Reduced to prayer at that point
and he convinced me that I was
perhaps being too judgmental
in that idea because
to sort of suggest
that Jefferson did not
believe in the divinity
of Christ he believed Jesus
was a great moral teacher
and that you should live
according to the precepts of Jesus
but not Jesus the Christ.
That's why he writes the Life and
Morals of Jesus of Nazareth instead
of Jesus Christ and when
he takes out the Bible,
he scissors out parts -- razors out
parts of the Bible that he considers
to be the mysticism and
sort of magical thinking.
But he convinced me that I had too
narrow of a view of all of this.
So that was an area that
he persuaded me about.
We had other small disputes
and sometimes you just
you know, just let it go.
It was the song -- the
movie with let it go,
let it go [inaudible]
let it go, let it go.
No I'm not going to sing it,
no I'm not going to sing that.
But we didn't have a lot,
we basically agreed --
the basic understanding
about Jefferson it's not
that different [inaudible].
>> Peter S. Onuf: What was wonderful
about this collaboration for me
and I think for both of us was that
we brought complimentary knowledge
and skills together and I think
the fit has been wonderful.
We've enjoyed working
together, the only down side
for me is I am now
known as a biographer,
I don't do biographies,
don't believe it.
>> Melissa Block: There are
two microphones by the way
if people want to make their way for
any questions that you might have,
feel free to come forward.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Well, here
comes some people, yay, questions.
>> Melissa Block: And you have
gotten there first so we're going
to go to this mic first, yeah.
>> Oh, I'm so excited to be
first, Annette I loved your book,
Hemings of Monticello, it's
been a huge inspiration for me.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Thank you.
>> And I'm writing a book
and I'm interested in craft,
a craft question for you, how --
what are the biggest
obstacles you had
in trying put together the sources
that you were using
to create a narrative?
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Well,
the biggest obstacle is actually
pulling it altogether and trying
to find the right way
to craft a narrative.
I mean to have lots of information,
to know what to go in and what to go
out -- what to leave in and what to
take out that's the biggest thing.
There was a lot there I
think but we don't have a lot
of direct evidence form or any
evidence from sally Hemings herself,
but you have to sort of
research around the situation.
It's funny because I didn't perceive
it as a problem, it was fun,
I mean I think I'm a natural
detective, I love to write
but I love to research, if not
more but certainly as much.
But I would say if I were
to say what a problem would
be it was learning how
to take the material and
turn it into a narrative
and to know I have a file -- the old
saying, you know kill your darlings.
I never killed them I
just sort of exiled them.
>> Peter S. Onuf: They're
still there.
They're zombies.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: They
are exiled, it's called outtakes
and you just take stuff and put
it away and say you may be able
to come back to that later on.
>> Melissa Block: On another day.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: So it
really is just paring things
down was the biggest problem.
>> Melissa Block: thank you
for your question, over here.
>> Yeah, Annette and Peter, the big
thing today in New York is Hamilton
and if you look at Chernow's book --
I've read your book, I've read a lot
of books, it's a big emphasis
of the fighting that went
on between Jefferson, Hamilton,
Adams and Madison joining
with Jefferson and others.
And you know -- it's and then
you know it's secretary of state
and leaving and I don't know whether
it was a temporary perspective
that Jefferson had during the
Washington administration.
And Washington is from Virginia.
And I was sort of surprised to
see after reading your books,
how Jefferson turned out to be evil.
Am I crazy or --
>> Peter S. Onuf: Did
you just say evil?
>> Evil, I mean because of he was
against the Washington's approach --
>> Peter S. Onuf: How many
times have you seen Hamilton?
>> I have the CD here, no, no, no
and also you know Miranda's book.
No, no, no the fact of looking
at Chernow's book he takes
a certain perspective.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Could
I start an answer?
>> Go ahead.
>> Peter S. Onuf: Okay and
Annette will set me right,
first of all the idea of
political opposition is
absolutely illegitimate.
Party faction no good, a
republic, we've been talking
about love ad nauseam,
it's supposed to be
that people do recognize
common values and commitments.
>> Yes.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And they don't
and of course love always makes --
failed love always
makes things worse.
As Freud would tell you
about love, hate and confect.
And the second thing is to
get back to the real world,
there's no guarantee that the
American Union will survive.
There's no guarantee that the United
States should ever cut a figure
in world affairs, it's from a
world historical perspective,
it's the odds against
it are tremendous.
In other words, there
is so much at stake.
>> Yes.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And of course
with the image of planting the seed
and this tree starts to grow in one
direction that could be forever.
They know they're starting something
and if they start it
wrong it will fail.
>> Right.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And so everything
is at stake and I personally
and I do get in trouble with
Annette on this, I'm a little hard
on Jefferson when we write
about politics, I don't know,
I understand what they're
both doing,
they make a lot of sense to me.
The physical military state,
Hamilton, he's got it.
Jefferson has the notion of how
to create a legitimate regime
that's going to connect people.
Forge new kinds of attachments
that will sustain the government.
All that makes sense, they
all made their contribution
but you can see what the stakes
are and why they would be
at each other's throats and all
because Washington is
listening to Hamilton too much.
>> Melissa Block: We only
have a few minutes left,
I want to go to another question.
>> I have two if you allow it.
>> Melissa Block: Fast.
>> Frist of all when I went to
Monticello one thing that occurred
to me was that what Jefferson was
doing relied a lot on his leisure,
his ability to just kind of spend
time on the things he wanted
to spend time on and so clearly he
relied heavily on slave ownership
in order to do those things.
And yet you are also saying that
he saw his lifestyle as a model
for people to live by, so in a
sense he thought that the model
of the republic would have had to
rely on the institution of slavery
for people to continue
to try to model that.
So was he conscious of that and how
would he deal with that in terms
of his idea of the ideal republic?
>> Melissa Block: All right
do you want to take that,
we're going to have to
leave it at one question
to try to get in someone else.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Well, I
think that he felt that eventually,
it's back to this point about
what would change later on,
he did not think the model
would not be slave owner
because eventually slavery would
go away and what he wanted would be
to have family farms, yeoman
farmers, they would take over.
But what he wanted people to
model was his ideas about science,
his ideas about art,
those kinds of things,
I don't think he saw plantation
life as a that aspect of his life.
It was the exalted, the more exalted
things and not just the institution
that he thought was going to leave.
>> Peter S. Onuf: And
one way of thinking
about it is his educational
system capped
by the university is the very
narrow apex of a great pyramid
that beings with primary education.
He doesn't think everybody
is going to reach the top,
so he's not modeling in that sense,
you might say that what has
characterized American middle class
society is its aspirational quality.
Be all you can be, be
learned, learn, be enlightened
and every man can participate
in enlightenment.
And I think that's the idea so that
anyone would be edified, educated
and enlightened by visiting
Monticello and pearls
of wisdom falling from the great
man, what a magnificent thing.
>> Melissa Block: One more
question before we have to break.
>> I'd like to go back to this issue
of writing a joint historical study
like this and perhaps you
could tell us a little bit
about how you got the idea of
working together on this book
and then how coordinated
different sections
or different aspects of the book.
>> Melissa Block: Sure, thank you.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: Okay,
well Peter said he was
going to retire and --
>> Peter S. Onuf: I did.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed: And he
did retire and I got the idea
that he should -- I didn't
want him to sort of ride off
into the sunset yet, and I asked him
to write a book with me [inaudible].
Well, you know it's what I
can do, I did what I could,
so that's how we got
the idea of doing it.
We've been talking to
each other since 1995
and I thought you know we should do
something together and so instead
of -- our editor wanted
us to have one voice.
So it wouldn't be good
for him to write a chapter
and me write a chapter,
just to do it like
and have somebody responsible
for different sections of it.
So we tried to write sections
and send them to each other.
We skyped every week for a period
of time when we were being very,
very efficient, we went out
on the road and we talked
about this quite a bit even
before we began to write.
So we wanted to try to craft
as much as we possibly could,
I mean there's some things,
some sections that are more him
and more me but everything we
all went over and approved it.
Changed sentences,
moved things around.
There's some little quirks and
whatever that I can recognize
that are mine and some that
I can recognize are him
but a lot times I don't
really know who wrote what.
>> Melissa Block: And they're
still talking [laughter].
Do we have time for
one more question?
We're over time, thank you.
Annette Gordon-Reed, Peter Onuf,
thank you so much [inaudible]
thank you for coming.
>> Annette Gordon-Reed:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.